jahrhundert projekt der eu
kommissionspräsident in ursula von der
leyen will europa bis 2050
klimafreundlich machen
entschädigung für thomas cook urlauber
die bundesregierung springt mit
steuergeldern 1 niederlage gegen
norwegen die deutschen handballerinnen
verpassen
das wm halbfinale
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten die vom sport hat
in knapp 15 minuten norbert lehmann
junior von mir
elf tage ist ursula von der leyen
präsidentin der eu kommission heute
legte sie einen ehrgeizigen klimaschutz
plan für europa vor
mit milliardeninvestitionen will sie den
strukturwandel der wirtschaft
vorantreiben
ein vorhaben das sie von der bedeutung
her mit der mondlandung vergleicht ihr
sogenannter green deal hat das ziel bis
2050 klimaneutralität für die gesamte
europäische union herzustellen heißt
viel weniger treibhausgase das ginge
aber nur mit extremen umstellungen in
der industrie der landwirtschaft der
energieversorgung und im verkehr aus
brüssel jetzt ina don't die leute die
kommissionssitzung ein und damit wohl
ein neues zeitalter
ursula von der leyen verspricht mit
ihrem klima paket nicht weniger als eine
grüne revolution
heute ist der beginn einer reise für
europa einen moment so bedeutend wie der
erste mensch auf dem mond ungewohnt
moment die kommission will den co2
ausstoß bis 2030 im vergleich zu 1990 um
50 bis 55 prozent reduzieren
sie stellt einen milliardenschweren
fonds bereit der allen regionen einen
fairen übergang ermöglicht wichtig ist
dieser form vor allem für länder wie
polen wo 78 prozent der energie immer
noch in kohlekraftwerken gewonnen wird
auch tschechien und ungarn gilt es vom
ziel der klimaneutralität bis 2050 noch
zu überzeugen
schon seit einiger zeit demonstrieren
europas bauern weil bestehende regeln
ihnen zu viel abverlangen und befürchten
nun dass der neue klimaplan ihre
existenz bedroht es mahnt auch die
industrie
weltklima werden wir nur retten wenn wir
in deutschland in europa die industrie
so leistungsfähig halten dass sie die
lösungen für energieeffiziente
produktion von morgen eher denken und
danach in die tat umsetzen können nicht
wenn wir sie daran hindern industrielle
fortschritte zu machen einen
gesetzesvorschlag nach dem anderen will
die eu kommission in den kommenden
jahren vorlegen verspricht von der leyen
sie sind ehrgeizig ihre pläne aber
durchsetzen wird sich nur was auch
eu-parlament und mitgliedsstaaten
mittragen tja und was die mittragen
dafür gibt es gleich morgen den ersten
test wenn sich die staats und
regierungschefs mit den plänen zur
klimaneutralität auseinandersetzen
müssen
anne gellinek in brüssel wie werden die
denn darauf reagieren also die ersten
reaktionen in den europäischen
hauptstädten vielen freundlicher und
positiv aus denn noch sind die
klimaschutzpläne der neuen kommission so
allgemein dass ich eigentlich alle
dahinter stellen können alle wollen
klimaneutralität sauberes wasser saubere
autos grüne landwirtschaft weniger co2
ausstoß aber die staats- und
regierungschefs die sich morgen hier zum
gipfeltreffen wissen natürlich dass eine
solche umkrempelung der wirtschaft sehr
viel geld kostet und sie ahnen auch wo
dieses geld zumindest teilweise
herkommen sollen nämlich aus dem eu
haushalt und damit aus den eu
mitgliedstaaten und damit hört die
freundlichkeit dann auch schon auf
morgen abend steht der neue eu haushalt
der siebenjährige auf dem programm des
gipfels und bislang gibt es sehr wenige
eu-staaten die bereit sind wirklich mehr
geld in den haushalt einzuzahlen auch
deutschland gehört bislang nicht dazu
und so kann von der leyen morgen zwar
mit abstraktem lob für ihre klimaziele
rechnen aber nicht mit konkreten
finanziellen zusagen die einschätzung
von einer klinik in brüssel vielen dank
dafür an eine rentenreform
was habe ich jetzt ja bis morgen ach so
ich war ein ton aus der regie hat mich
gerade irritiert eine rentenreform in
frankreich haben schon viele vergeblich
versucht der neue anlauf jetzt ist das
grosse projekt von präsident ma con
schon seit tagen gibt es heftige
proteste und streiks
obwohl die regierung ihre pläne erst
heute im detail präsentiert aktuell hat
frankreich 42 einzelne rentensysteme mit
vielen ausnahmen und privilegien
das soll sich ändern aber
premierminister philipp machte auch
zugeständnisse aus paris thomas walde
für premierminister philipp und
präsident makro ist die rentenreform zu
einer existenziellen frage geworden um
die reform durchzusetzen versuchte
philipp heute kritiker zu besänftigen
das universelle rentensystem der
regierung ist ein projekt der sozialen
gerechtigkeit es gibt keine
hintergedanken
wir wollen nicht hier oder da ein
bisschen sparen
wer ohne abstriche in rente will muss
künftig statt bis 62 bis 64 arbeiten die
42 einzelnen rentenkassen sollen
schrittweise abgeschafft und durch ein
universelles punktesystem ähnlich wie in
deutschland ersetzt werden
es wird eine mindestrente von 1000 euro
netto geben einkommen über 120000 euro
im jahr zahlen einen solidarbeitrag
betroffen sind nur menschen die jünger
als 44 jahre sieht die regierung will
details mit den sozialpartnern
verhandeln
der verweis auf die gerechte gestaltung
soll ein ende der streiks bewirken
doch die reaktionen von gewerkschaftern
fallen kritisch aus wie erwartet wurde
keiner der vorschläge unserer
gewerkschaft aufgenommen in dem was man
uns hier präsentiert hat der
premierminister behauptet nur dass er
zum dialog bereit sei wir hatten eine
rote linie definiert und diese rote
linie war dass man künftig nicht länger
arbeiten muss als bisher
schon kurz nach dem mega phillipe seiner
reform vorgestellt hatte wie ich die
erste gewerkschaft dazu auf den streik
zu intensivieren
die machtprobe mit der regierung geht
weiter nach den haag zum internationalen
gerichtshof dort wird darüber verhandelt
ob es in myanmar einen völkermord an der
muslimischen minderheit der rohingya
gegeben hat das ws myanmars
regierungschefin augen sanssouci heute
zurück sie sprach von einem bewaffneten
konflikt das militär habe auf
muslimische extremisten reagiert dabei
habe es möglicherweise auch übergriffe
gegeben
die klage gegen myanmar bezieht sich auf
einen un bericht der dem militär
systematischer gewalt vorwirft
die welthandelsorganisation wto hat in
dem vierteljahrhundert ihres bestehens
rund 600 mal streit in handelsfragen
geschichtet so groß ihr verdienst so
dringend erscheint vielen eine
grundlegende reform der wto denn seit
heute fehlt ihr die zweite instanz das
schiedsgericht weil die usa die
neubesetzung von richterposten
blockieren
was das bedeutet erklärt kurz und knapp
christoph distel
eigentlich ist es eine erfolgsgeschichte
164 länder machen mit bei der wto also
fast die gesamte welt die spielregeln
sind simpel geraten zwei länder in
streit etwa in zollfragen gehen sie zur
wto geschlichtet und ganz wichtig was
sie sagt gilt dann auch zuletzt etwa im
fall usa gegen eu
da ging es um staatshilfen für airbus
illegale entschieden die richter und
erlaubten den usa strafzölle in
milliarden höhe
aber der glanz der wto verblasst weil
sie in rasenden zeiten selbst stehen
geblieben ist ein beispiel
nach wie vor gelten zwei drittel der
mitglieder auch china als
entwicklungsländer und bekommen eine
sonderbehandlung reformen längst
überfällig doch sie scheitern weil jedes
einzelne land ein vetorecht hat jetzt
also die amerikanische notbremse im
herzstück der wto bei der
streitschlichtung nur noch ein richter
am abend keine urteile mehr möglich für
künftige handelsstreits könnte das
bedeuten
ruppiger der stärkere gewinnt unruhige
zeiten gerade deutschland der große
exporteur ahnte schlimmes
ja und deshalb gleich mal die frage an
frank bethmann an der börse in frankfurt
frank was heißt das denn nun für die
deutsche wirtschaft wenn die wto nicht
mehr funktioniert dann geht natürlich
ein stück weit verlässlichkeit und
vertrauen verloren wer wie deutsche
unternehmen viel ins ausland verkaufte
ist in den letzten jahrzehnten ganz gut
damit gefahren dass sie zu niedrig waren
dass man bei der ausfuhr nicht lange an
grenzen warten musste und bei problemen
gab es ja noch die schiedsstelle die
verbindlich recht sprechen konnte alles
steht jetzt auf dem spiel weil es in
diesem machtkampf zwischen china und den
usa eskaliert die usa vor allem beklagen
dass china unfair spiele stichworte
unerlaubte subventionen oder technologie
klaubt und die usa haben jetzt selber
mit gezinkten karten gespielt indem sie
die wto schachmatt gesetzt haben vorerst
keine regeln mehr nur noch die eigenen
das gesetz des stärkeren für den rest
sind das natürlich bis auf weiteres
keine guten nachrichten vielleicht am
treffendsten kommentiert dass der
verband der chemischen industrie der vom
wild west im welthandel spricht vielen
dank für die analyse frank bethmann in
frankfurt wir bleiben an der börse dort
hat der saudiarabische ölgigant aramco
einen staat der superlative hingelegt
nur sekunden nach handelsbeginn stieg
der kurs der aktie um zehn prozent
aramco nahm 25,6 milliarden us dollar
ein
der ölkonzern ist jetzt das wertvollste
unternehmen der welt
die einnahmen sollen in neue
großprojekte schließen
bisher ist die saudiarabische wirtschaft
ausschließlich vom ölgeschäft abhängig
gute nachrichten für kunden des
insolventen reiseriesen thomas cook
deutsche pauschalurlauber bekommen jetzt
auch ihr volles geld zurück und zwar mit
hilfe des staates
bislang waren reisen nur durch einen
versicherer abgedeckt bis zu einer
gesetzlichen obergrenze von 110
millionen euro pro jahr
doch das reicht nicht aus durch die
pleite ist ein schaden von rund 287
millionen euro entstanden
die lücke will jetzt der bund schließen
doch der rückgriff auf steuergelder
wirft fragen auf heike slansky
handwerksmeister tino kopitzsch gezeigt
uns urlaubsbilder aus teneriffa
weil's so schön war wollte er wieder hin
doch die thomascook pleite machte ihm
einen strich durch die rechnung
wenn du dich die ganze zeit aus dem
urlaub reist kommt der schock da noch
hinterher dass du nur ich sag mal ein
fünftel wieder bekommst von dem was du
dir eigentlich zusammen gespart hast
eben selbst
über meldete der konzern insolvenz an da
der reiseveranstalter nur bis zu 110
millionen euro versichert war blieben
viele betroffene auf einem teil ihrer
kosten sitzen jetzt springt der
steuerzahler ein entschied die
bundesregierung aus gründen des
vertrauensschutzes wird die
bundesregierung deshalb den reisenden
die schäden ersetzen die sie nicht
ausgeglichen bekommen
der bund wird sich aber im gegenzug die
ansprüche abtreten lassen und diese
ansprüche aus einer hand verfolgen heißt
wer die entschädigung an dem tritt seine
ansprüche an den bund ab und ist damit
raus wie viel geld der staat dann
eintreiben kann ist offen es kann nicht
sein dass die gewinne von konzernen
privatisiert aber die verluste dann
verstaatlicht werden
die bundesregierung hatte anders als
eine eu-richtlinie vorgab eine
obergrenze bei der versicherungs höhe
erlaubt eine deckelung die jetzt
hunderte millionen kosten könnte die
reisen haben sich darauf verlassen dass
sie geschützt werden die reisebranche
hat damit geworben pauschalreise sind
gesichert sofern davon jetzt die
verbraucher die darauf vertraut haben
dass dieses recht gilt nicht im regen
stehen lassen noch sind viele fragen
offen
kino kopitzsch gehe jedenfalls freut
sich hat gleich eine neue reise gebucht
heraus ins land zu den menschen
bundespräsident steinmeier war heute
unterwegs in sachsen in der stadt
pulsnitz mit seinem besuch wollte er ein
zeichen setzen gegen zunehmende
bedrohung von kommunalpolitikern die
bürgermeisterin der stadt war immer
wieder angefeindet worden
steinmeier traf außerdem auch pulsnitzer
bürger um mit ihnen über die politische
stimmung vor ort zu diskutieren
alarmierende zahlen zum thema
lebensmittelsicherheit die verbraucher
organisation foodwatch bemängelt dass
entgegen den vorschriften
lebensmittel-hersteller restaurants und
imbiss leben oft nicht kontrolliert
werden
wegen personalmangels bei den
zuständigen behörden seien im
vergangenen jahr 250.000 pflicht
kontrollen ausgefallen
der berufsverband schätzt dass
bundesweit 1500 lebensmittelkontrolleure
fehlen
geht es nach den buchmachern im
wettbegeisterten großbritannien ist der
fall klar
boris johnson gewinnt die parlamentswahl
morgen bleibt also premierminister und
führt das land aus der eu er selbst gibt
sich da nicht ganz so sicher
es könnte nicht enger sein sagte heute
am letzten wahlkampftag reist quer
durchs land und kämpft um jede stimme
andreas stamm aus london er ist sich für
nichts zu schade boris johnson der am
morgen als einfacher milchmann seine
einfache botschaft präsentiert wie jeden
tag in diesem wahlkampf
wir erledigen den dragset ein fertiger
die liegt auf dem tisch wir müssen nach
vorne gehen eines muss man johnson
lassen er weiß ihr die botschaft der
wähler schmackhaft macht der praxis dann
den exit erledigen gewinnt er wird es am
31 januar den drei mal verschobenen
austritt geben die umfragen sehen den
premier klar vorne doch der vorsprung
schrumpft
die lobgesänge auf jeremy corbijn
verfrüht doch seine labour partei holt
auf er verspricht ein zweites referendum
doch viel lieber spricht corbijn über
die konservativen
entweder wir wählen die fortführung der
sparpolitik mit riesiger armut und
unsicherheit für viele oder eine labour
regierung die wirklich in die zukunft
investiert die die wahrheit über den
dreck wie gefährlich johnson soziale
themen etwa die krise im
gesundheitssystem werden können zeigt
dieses foto
ein vierjähriger muss auf dem boden der
notaufnahme schlafen kein bett mehr frei
für ein kind wohl mit lungenentzündung
die reaktion des premiers als ihn ein
reporter das foto auf dem handy zeigt im
urteil vieler kaltherzig ohne
einfühlungsvermögen einer seiner wenigen
großen fehltritte im wahlkampf doch die
praxis müdigkeit der briten scheint
johnson den sieg zu schenken und das
talent schlechte nachrichten und das
mangelnde vertrauen des wählers in
seiner glaubwürdigkeit aus dem weg zu
räumen
brachial mit der immer gleichen
einfachen botschaft zum sport und zum
aus für die deutschen handballerinnen
bei der wm in japan norbert ja aus der
traum halbfinale verpasst aus der traum
von einer wm medaille nach dem 29 32
pleite gegen rekord-europameister
norwegen beginnt jetzt auch noch das
große zittern um die olympia
qualifikation wieder ein wichtiges spiel
verloren fünf schnelle gegentore kurz
nach der pause und die dhb auswahl in
weiß liegt gegen rekord-europameister
norwegen im japanischen kumamoto klar
zurück schon am montag hatte das team
von bundestrainer hingegen knapp gegen
serbien verloren
jetzt muss ein unentschieden her fürs
halbfinale doch der treffer zum 29 32
durch michael schmelzer fünf minuten vor
schluss ist der letzte für die deutschen
frauen mit 32 29 gewinnt norwegen am
freitag geht es für deutschland gegen
schweden noch um platz sieben nur wer
gewinnt nimmt im märz am olympia
qualifikationsturnier teil
bayern münchen will nach dem letzten
bundesliga hinrundenspiel am 21 dezember
entscheiden ob hansi flick cheftrainer
des fcb bleibt das teilte heute
vorstandschef karl heinz rummenigge mit
ja was für ein champions league abend
gruppen-erster barcelona siegt bei inter
mailand und dortmund zittert sich
zeitgleich ins achtelfinale
durch den knappen 2 2 1 -sieg gegen
slavia prag der held des abends der
bvb-keeper dortmunds torwart butt einen
abend der superlative
roman bürki spielte das beste spiel
seiner karriere ein sensationelles spiel
gemacht heute haben wir gerade in der
kabine natürlich gefeiert
berechtigterweise ich glaube er hat
jetzt genug selbstvertrauen für die
nächsten zwei drei wochen brand royce
sancho drei stationen vor dortmunds
führung nach zehn minuten
auch der engländer steht für das
wiedererstarken der borussia einmal
konnte selbst bürki gegen die starken
prager nichts mehr machen
der ausgleich durch zach nach 43 minuten
damit wäre dortmund ausgeschieden
gewesen hätte nicht julian brandt nach
61 minuten überraschend die vordere ecke
gewählt 2 2 1 dank blog super tolles
gefühl habe mich sehr berührt und dann
werde ich auch immer nicht immer daran
erinnern und mein ganzes leben lang
nicht nur er
leipzig als gruppen-erster ebenfalls im
achtelfinale in bayern sind schon weiter
und leverkusen könnte es heute abend
auch noch kunden danken wir haben jetzt
noch die zahlen vom mittwoch soll die
gewinnzahlen lauten 14 25 27 32 36 45
und die superzahl 5 weitere gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto punkt zdf.de und
dem zdf text auf seite 55 7
die wetteraussichten kommen gleich von
katja honnefer so viel von uns schön
dass sie dabei waren
um drei viertel 10 marietta slomka und
das heute-journal und morgen freut sich
an dieser stelle wie der christian
sievers auf sie
schönen abend noch physisches
[Musik]
den abend meine damen und herren das war
ein richtiges orkantief dass island
heute überquert hat das brachte
windgeschwindigkeiten von über 200
kilometer pro stunde mit für uns hier in
deutschland ist weniger der wind als
vielmehr dieses wolkenband interessant
aus dem ist ja heute glatteisregen regen
und schnee gab und die begleiten und sie
jetzt auch am abend und durch die nacht
denn etwa zwischen mecklenburg
vorpommern und dem bodensee kann es
gefährlich glatt werden auf den straßen
durch eben schnee schneeregen und
glatteisregen morgen allerdings
verlassen uns die schnee- und regenfälle
immer mehr ostwärts und dann kann sich
im westen sogar mal die sonne zeigen
heute nacht allerdings machen sie sich
bitte auf gefährlich glatte straßen
gefasst etwa südlich von eifel sauerland
und spreewald bei tiefsttemperaturen
zwischen 0 und -4 grad im norden ist es
trüb und an der ostsee fällt etwas regen
und morgen kann sich dann im westen
tatsächlich kurz die sonne zeigen
und zwar zwischen dem emsland und dem
oberrhein und der nordsee reicht
vielleicht sogar mal für gewitter die
schneefälle verlassen uns und im
nordosten bleibt es trüb
die höchsttemperaturen liegen morgen
zwischen 0 grad an den alpen und 6 grad
am oberrhein
und dann kommt der freitag und damit
neuer schnee zum dritten advent müssen
wir uns dann auf sturm einstellen